this was one of the most important
realizations I ever had when I was at
PCS which is what my inner monologue
sounded like I called that Bobby Knight
coach Knight is going to strangle you if
you make a mistake this exercise that
they had me do there
was one of the most powerful things I've
ever done every single day
two or three times something is going to
happen that's going to prompt you to
want to scream at yourself take out your
phone and record a message
but look into the eyes of your best
friend and pretend that they made that
mistake what would you say to them hey
Peter I know it's frustrating you you
just didn't have a good drive today but
you know I think I think there's a lot
on your mind today and and I mean the
first few times I did this I was in
tears
because it was such a shift of how kind
I would speak to that person and in just
four months of being mindful of this
every single day
I don't even remember it's so hard for
me to remember Bobby's voice